having sex for money was not his plan
when I first moved out to LA I had about
a thousand dollars saved up that went
very quickly I was bouncing from my
friend's couch to my other friend's
couch to a motel into a French couch you
know like just kind of finding my way
sometimes I would walk up and down
Sunset Boulevard because I just like to
you know look in the bars and imagine
myself being able to afford a meal there
one day I would occasionally open up
grinder grinder is very aggressive I got
a message from a guy who didn't have a
picture up I couldn't see his face and
just saying like hey can I blow you and
I was like I was like I'm not really
feeling it today and I went back to my
friends place to crash
he kept messaging me all night as I
later discovered he was like please
employee like he looks so straight like
who's that girl in your picture cuz I
had to grow a picture he thought that it
was my girlfriend now I'm not straight
in the game world there's this whole
fantasy of like turning a straight guy
just like for straight dudes there's a
whole fantasy about you know turning a
lesbian I was like thank you good and
he's like well I'll pay what do you mean
you give me money the [ __ ] you know and
I was like a little bit insulting at
first I had never been paid for sex
before I don't have any money
I'm just getting a [ __ ] from this
dude I could probably kick his ass and
stuff go south if I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna get a bunch of [ __ ] money for
it look at how much he was like a
hundred dollars and I'm like three
hundred dollars and he's like okay let's
call it an even 240 which is a really
awkward number when you think about it
but two hundred and forty dollars more
than I had as someone was going down he
ordered me an uber from my first place
all the way up to his way up in the hill
freez everywhere the houses were
freaking huge
I felt really dirty and awkward in the
car so I like lied to the Luper driver
and said that I was going to pick up a
script for my manager Oh
I mean the uber driver didn't give a
[ __ ] and I was also nervous like what if
he didn't pay me what if I was like
walking into some kind of trap I didn't
let myself be consumed by those thoughts
when I got to the place you look so
manly and I'm like alright that's thanks
he was probably hot when he was younger
but he didn't really take care of
himself on that well the only thing I
remember on the wall was a record from
one of the artists that he hadn't worked
with he was a music executive no wonder
you have so much money he sits me down
on the couch he also turns on a straight
porn that I could watch to help me get
off because I didn't have to pay
attention to him at all takes off his
shirt asking me to play with his nipples
he asked me like what it was like to
[ __ ] girls all the time and like how
straight I was and yada yada yada like
this is like easily the weirdest small
talk I've ever had with anyone I
couldn't get it up just give me a second
let me go pee so I go to piss and and
I'd like you know get myself up and
think about texts and stuff
it came back out no look let's do it and
it goes rather well he wasn't bad I
don't know why he had to pay somebody
else to do it
after I'd you know finished I was like
well you know I've got to get back to my
girlfriend
good job well I mean there was a bit of
shame but you know I just got a [ __ ]
and I have a ton of money in my pocket
so I felt a lot better and the guy was
like alright that's that's awesome you
know if you ever want to come by again
like I went over there maybe three times
a couple of times after that I used to
pay for a plane ticket back home for
Christmas my mom and I usually we try to
like split it 5050 and the sound like I
could this is gonna be great again my
mom was like oh my god how did you make
the money don't worry about it if my mom
found out she would probably flipper
[ __ ] it's a secret that I've only told
very very very few people it's not that
I'm ashamed of it it's just I don't
really feel like dealing with their
reactions it's not really any different
from having casual sex through tinder or
Grindr you know it doesn't really affect
anybody other than me and the person
who's giving me that money so why the
[ __ ] do you care
[Music]